alors que la ville dort encore c'est
l'effervescence à la plateforme de
distribution bisontine les
semi-remorques arrive rempli à bloc à
l'intérieur des colis en vrac traité 1 1
et à la main d'abord flashé preuve
qu'ils sont bien arrivés à besançon ils
sont ensuite dispatcher avant de
rejoindre d'autres centres de tri du
petit il ya beaucoup plus de quantité
que d'habitude par rapport à l'année
dernière
c'est toujours comme ça va trois heures
du matin pour réussir à suivre qui
corrobore au vélo derrière ça c'est
fatiguant comme on arrive à suivre
correctement le seuil des 20 mille colis
par jour a été franchie contre 8000 en
moyenne le reste de l'année une hausse
d'activité arriver dès début novembre
soit quinze jours plus tôt prévu il a
fallu s'adapter
il ya deux séances de tri d'eau qui a
une arrivée de camions à 4 heures du
matin ces colis là seront emportés toute
la journée
voilà et que nous commençons à recevoir
d'autres camions à partir de 14 heures
et ces colis là seront distribués le
lendemain et entoure on est sur une
trentaine de personnes en plus de
l'effectif habituel
un effectif qui a été plus que doublée
2020 et c'est confinement à répétition a
vu une explosion du commerce en ligne
que la poste doit gérer le trafic colis
augmentent il faut être aussi bien
conscient que le
le trafic courrier lui a diminué voilà
donc sans que l'un compense
nécessairement l'autre c'est c'est pas
tout à fait on ne peut pas dire que ce
soit tout à fait une bonne année pour le
groupe la peau si plus de colis envoyés
c'est logiquement plus de colis à
distribuer aux particuliers dès 8 heures
du matin ou qu'il faut déposer dans les
différents points relais ici à la gare
en général j'en ai maximum 5 en période
normale
et là c'est vraiment oui c'est fait
grand champ ni 24 la même si tous les
commerces ont rouvert leurs portes ce
rythme soutenu devrait se poursuivre au
moins jusqu'à noël